I would tell you fox probably has the  worst terms you guys want to play some  games Fox guests aren't allowed on this  show  yeah not a lot you watch Fox actually  I don't know about contractually I just  know that probably pissing off Fox right  now yeah like we we routinely have  people say stuff like I wish I'm a big  fan we love the show we'd love to come  on too bad we can't by the way Fox  whoever you guys have your people come  on because it would be phenomenal for  all of us isn't this show specifically  or just any podcast form this show is  specifically blacklisted for Fox  personalities  um that doesn't make any sense to me oh  that makes absolute sense we compete  directly with Tucker Carlson yeah a lot  of people see a competition instead of  actually you know working together  cohesively there's also uh prageru Epoch  times there's a lot of media  organizations in the space that do have  the money that could facilitate